هم سيبداون بالتوافد على المناطق المحيطه
في ابنا هذه المدينه التي لا تزال عمليات
الانقاذ فيها مستمره عمليات الاحتياج فيها
ايضا مستمره بالاضافه الى احتياج الكبير
ايضا المدن الثانيه سيتم توزيع هذا الفريق
مباشره على اقرب منطقه تحتاج فيها سلطات
التركيه تواجد هذا الفريق
فسيذهبون مباشره بدءا من المطار الى داخل
المدينه مباشره للقيام بعمليات الانقاذ من
الفريق الالقاب بالاضافه الى القيام
بعمليات الاسعاف في الفريق الاسعافي
المتخصص من قبل الهلال الاحمر بالاضافه
الى مركز الملك سلمان الذي سيقوم بتوزيع
هذه المساعدات مباشره على المناطق الاكثر
احتياجا وهنا نتحدث عن مناطق ربما تبعد ما
يقارب 150 كيلو الى 100 كيلو من مطار اضنه
من مدينه اضنه وهي مدينه تعرضت للضرر ولكن
هنالك مدن اخرى تعرضت لضرر اكبر وتحديدا
نتحدث عن المدينه التي ضربها هذا الزلزال
المركز هذا الزلزال بالتالي سيتم توزيع
المساعدات مباشره تحديدا لمساعدات
الايوائيه التي ستكون مباشره متواجده في
تلك المناطق وهي من ابرز الاحتياجات في
هذا الوقت خصوصا مع هذا الطقس شديد
البروده فبالتالي سيتم العمل مباشره
ينسقون مع الجانب السعودي على عمليه
مباشره هذه
التحميل هذه المساعدات مباشره التي تستعد
للنزول الان حقيقه بعضها نزل ولكن البعض
الاخر لم ينزل حتى الان ربما يوجد ضغط على
هذا المطار نظرا لوجود وكثره الفرق
اللغاتيه التي شاهدتها في هذا المطار من
مختلف انحاء العالم فبالتالي يتم الانتظار
الى حين تنزيل هذه
المساعدات من هذه الطائره الشاحن السعوديه
لمباشره عمليه
الاغاثه في هذه المدينه وفي المدن الاخرى
الاكثر احتياجا مطار اضنه هو الوحيد حاليا
في هذه المنطقه والمناطق المحيطه التي
ضربها الزلزال الوحيد القادر على
القادر على
استقبال هذه الطائرات بهذا الشكل فبالتالي
يتم التعامل مع الجسر الجوي الجسر الجوي
السعودي مباشره مع هذا المطار على بشكل
عادل وربما خلال الايام القليله القادمه
بدءا من هذه الطائره وحتى الطائرات الاخرى
خالد على ما يبدو ان الفريق يستعد الان
للدخول الى داخل المدينه